the highly anticipated Victoria's Secret
Fashion Show is here and the Angels
brought all of their Angel appeal to the
catwalk it was taped in New York City
Thursday night at airs December 2nd from
the wings to the lingerie Oh stunning
glowing scintillating sexuality
gorgeousness girl power so many
adjectives that we can use for these
women there's kendall Jenner with an
explosion coming out of her back and
then you know paying homage to clueless
little plaid moment Gigi Hadid I don't
know is that a full parachute Bella
Hadid no matter what she's wearing the
ABS are insane so we'll take it now guys
look not everyone can look like this and
these women work there's Behati Prinsloo
work hard to look like this there is no
other fashion show I think that women
train harder for as models because they
know every inch of them border line will
be on display and of course et was on
hand to talk to all of the models about
the show the taping and how it all went
and about most importantly the meals
they eat afterwards because once you
power through this you deserve a break
here's what they had to say about what
they binge on after the big night I'm
just craving like pasta with like cream
sauce and bacon pizza
then I'm gonna go find desert
shake-shake-shake shake-shake-shake
burger and buy a good white pizza
somewhere I'm gonna I'm gonna look where
I'm gonna hunt it down give me the pizza
okay pizza and Shake Shack for the win
yes you heard them I'll talk about it
and what a boyfriend dylan sprouse was
on hand to support his model girlfriend
Barbara Palvin and look at this he came
through with a bag of burgers Dylan we
applaud you bringing his woman the
burger that she needed I mean a couple
goals is this real yes it is he even
posed with it loved it so a super fun
night we had these amazing performers of
course Shawn Mendes Victoria's Secret
Show always brings it out to many
beautiful people in one photo Halsey
performed also performing and by the way
Halsey said she'd worked so hard for
this because she wore some revealing
ensembles herself also performing the
chainsmokers bebe Rexha I think you're
seeing here Rita Ora performed what did
read or to perform guys I got that on my
cardi but that was bebe Rexha she did
Rita Ora did - okay good and we want to
get the Victoria's Secret facts straight
for everybody
and Kelsea Ballerini performing - so
we've got the photos we will see the
actual show in December but it was the
end of a Victoria's Secret area era
Adriana Lima here she is hanging up
those wings after nearly 20 years as an
angel each he was with Adriana at her
very first Victoria's Secret Show if you
can believe it take a look
I feel little nervous how would you
describe the clothes it's sexy and the
same time daily Kate you know it's so
good I think so weird I love it it's the
best honestly she looks the same
Rihanna told us on Thursday that the
Victoria's Secret Fashion Show has been
her life and her first love so
everybody's sad to see her go
[Music]